show revolves around a time traveler
named the doctor and his new companion
Rose Tyler in the opening scene he asks
her where she wants to go for her maiden
voyage aboard the Tardis a spaceship
that can Traverse through time and space
Rose expresses her desire to travel
forward in time precisely one century
into the future the doctor finds the
request a bit odd but nonetheless he
activates his time machine the next
second they both find themselves in the
22nd century which doesn't seem very
interesting hence the two have a change
of heart and decide to embark on a
further future Journey leading them to
arrive in the year twelve thousand and
five the era of the new Roman Empire
however Rose is skeptical of the
doctor's explanations so in an effort to
impress her he takes her further to a
space station orbiting Earth 5 billion
years into the future five billion as
they look on and wonder they witness the
sun beginning to expand prompting the
doctor to utter the words welcome to the
end of the world the doctor goes on to
explain Humanity has left Earth a long
time ago and the planet has been taken
over by the National Trust who uses
gravity satellites to hold back the
sun's effects however the funds for this
are dwindling and according to him the
Earth will eventually be consumed by the
Sun the wealthiest and most powerful
beings in the universe will witness the
world's demise which the doctor claims
will occur in around half an hour
despite his knowledge of the situation
the doctor appears to have no intention
of saving the planet in addition he
informs rose that the space station they
are on is equipped with automated
systems and manned by blue skinned
humanoids after a brief period the duo
stumbles upon an extraterrestrial being
with blue skin named Steward who is
responsible for managing Platform One
within the space station when Steward
inquires about the Duo's identities the
doctor shows a special piece of psychic
paper convincing Steward that they are
invited guests once he gets inside the
doctor reveals the secret behind the
psychic paper explaining that it has the
power to influence how people see things
according according to his will
afterwards the remaining invitees begin
to arrive each with their own unique
characteristics and peculiarities first
to arrive is mocks of baloon a
diminutive being followed by the face of
Bo a living entity with a distinct
appearance the group is then joined by a
contingent of humanoid trees from the
forest of cheem and a group of hooded
aliens called the adherence of the
repeated meme lastly Cassandra the last
living human enters the scene her
appearance is quite unusual as she turns
out to be a piece of stretched out skin
that has been mounted onto a frame with
a brain jar connected to it it appears
that her skin needs constant
moisturization from her attendance to
ensure that she remains hydrated once
all of the guests have arrived they
begin to exchange gifts with one another
jabe of the forest of cheem offers the
doctor a cutting taken from her
grandfather which he gratefully accepts
in return the doctor presents her with
the gift of air from his lungs the MOX
provides the doctor with a gift of
bodily saliva while the adherence of the
repeated meme distribute Gifts of Peace
in the form of metal spheres out of
preferred sad Keanu but thanks anyways
guys Cassandra being the last to present
her gift hands over an ostrich egg and
an ancient Earth iPod the iPod plays
classical music which proves to be
overwhelming for us who eventually
leaves the hall in the next scene as
Rose wanders around the station she
comes across a plumber named rafalo who
is in the midst of investigating a
blockage amidst the conversation Rose
suddenly feels a sense of vulnerability
and fear realizing how far she is from
her home with a person she does not know
concerned about her safety she hastily
departs leaving her follow to continue
with her work while examining the ducts
rafalo spots a group of small
spider-like robots that quickly grab
hold of her and drag her inside it
becomes apparent that these robots are
emerging from the metal spheres that
were gifted to the guests by the
adherence of the repeated meme they soon
infiltrate the entire station sabotaging
its systems elsewhere the doctor finds
Rose sitting alone in a quiet room upon
seeing him she immediately asks about
his Origins and where he comes from how
however the doctor simply brushes off
her inquiry leaving her feelings
somewhat bewildered and perplexed in an
attempt to ease Rose's concerns and
provide her with some comfort the doctor
Alters her mobile phone allowing her to
call her mother five billion years in
the past 5 billion her mood instantly
left says she chats with her mother on
the phone the doctor then playfully
mentions that if Rose thinks her phone
call was amazing she should wait to see
the bill at the same time a Tremor
shakes the station and the doctor
nervously explains that it was not
supposed to happen on the other hand
Stewart is in the process of examining
the reason behind the unanticipated
shaking movement as he delves into his
investigation a spider-like robot shows
up and Alters the positioning of the
solar filter within his chamber as a
consequence Stewart becomes vulnerable
to the direct scorching heat emanating
from the sun's rays which is more than
450 Celsius this Burns him to a crisp in
a matter of seconds Steward you poor
bastard following the Tremor the doctor
also embarks on a quest to investigate
its cause and jabe offers to guide him
to the maintenance corridors until they
return Rose decides to approach
Cassandra and then cover more about her
during their conversation Cassandra
discloses that she has undergone a
staggering 708 cosmetic procedures and
considers herself to be the only
remaining pure human she believes that
the remaining are intermingled with
other species and calls them mongrels
this offensive remark towards Humanity
prompts Rose to express her disgust
towards Cassandra and storm away
abandoning the conversation however the
adherent soon follow her and upon
reaching an empty Corridor their leader
violently strikes her on the head
rendering her unconscious before
dragging her away elsewhere jabe takes
the doctor towards the innermost parts
of the space station as they descend
deeper and deeper they stumble upon one
of the enigmatic spiders jabe manages to
trap it with her elongated vine-like
appendage but they are still at a loss
as to why the spider is there and what
its purpose is few moments later Rose
regains her Consciousness only to find
herself trapped in a room where the sun
filter is slowly being lowered she cries
out for help unfortunately the doctor
hears her please he somehow manages to
raise the sun filter but is still unable
to unlock the door to free her as a
result he decides to release the spider
robot in hopes of locating its
controller to everyone's surprise it
scurries over to the adherence of the
repeated meme however the doctor is
aware that the meme is just a decoy so
he exposes them as robots making them
collapse to the ground after this he
once again deploys the spider robot to
track down the source of the control
which leads him to Cassandra this
finally reveals that she is The
Mastermind behind the entire scheme
Cassandra who is now exposed orders her
attendance to hold the others at Bay
while warning them the moisturizer guns
have the potential to shoot acid she
reveals that her numerous and costly
cosmetic procedures have left her
financially depleted and she was hoping
to create a hostage situation where she
could pretend to be one of the victim
and later seek a compensation but now
with everything out in the open
Cassandra decides to let everyone burn
as the shares she holds in rival
companies of the guests will Skyrocket
in value following this she orders the
spider robots to deactivate the force
field that has been protecting the space
station she then employs a teleportation
device to transport herself as well as
her attendance away leaving the others
to fend for themselves with only a few
minutes remaining before the sun
destroys the earth and the space station
the doctor and jabe hurry back to the
air conditioning chamber to restore the
computer systems unfortunately the
restore switch is located at the far end
of a platform that is obstructed by
enormous rotating fans jabe bravely
steps forward to hold down the switch
that slows the fans despite the doctor's
concerns that the rising heat will set
her wooden body Ablaze jabe however
remains Resolute in her determination in
order to save the people inside the
station meanwhile the doctor rushes
towards the other side of the platform
making it almost to the end but
unfortunately jabe catches fire and
burns as a result the fan speeds up
making it even more difficult for the
doctor to make his way through
nonetheless he has no other option but
to concentrate and push on closing his
eyes and focusing his mind on the task
at hand finally he crosses the last fan
squeezes through it and promptly pushes
the reset switch the force fields
immediately go up around the space
station just as the Earth explodes into
Cinders after the catastrophic event the
station's self-repairing systems get
activated several of the guests are now
incinerated as the sun's Rays burst
through the cracks in the windows
meanwhile the doctor finds Cassandra's
teleportation feed inside the ostrich
egg and reverses it to bring her back
however she remains arrogant and mocks
him stating that he is powerless against
her nevertheless the doctor calmly
reveals that he only transported
Cassandra and not her moisturizing
attendance and as the heat intensifies
Cassandra starts to dry out causing her
to beg for mercy Rose asks the doctor to
save her but he responds coldly stating
that everything has its time and must
come to an end ooh ice cold doc
eventually Cassandra's skin stretches
and tears apart leading to her innards
exploding and leaving behind only her
brain tank and an empty frame the
intense situation is now under control
but Rose feels a sense of sadness as she
realizes that in the midst of all the
dangers the destruction of Earth had
gone unnoticed by anyone the doctor then
decides to take her back to the present
time in his Tardis later we see the
doctor and Rose standing among the
people on Earth during this he shares a
bit of wisdom with her he observes that
human beings tend to take things for
granted and assume that everything is
permanent when in reality nothing lasts
forever the doctor then discloses that
his home planet was also destroyed in a
war much like Earth he sadly admits that
he is the last survivor of the time
Lords feeling an immense burden of
loneliness hearing this Rose Comforts
him assuring him that he is not alone
because she will always be by his side
in the last scene the two had to enjoy
some chips as they believed that they
have only 5 billion years before the
shops close subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching